Good morning everybody.
And the last thing between you and lunch, I suspect.
I'm Ryan, I'm a principal product manager at
Amazon. I'm joined by my colleague Nick, who's gonna
come up here about halfway through.
I've been really looking forward to talking to you all
week. I lost my voice yesterday
though, so please bear with me if you feel
my voice break or
I stop for some water.
I'm, Nick and I are both from the Strand's
agents team.
We've been really looking forward to talking to you about
strands at this conference. Many of you maybe
have seen our booth,
um, and today we're here to talk about our newest
release TypeScript, some of the other releases around
it, and, uh, I'm gonna spend some
time talking about
this simple interface for building
an agent, and I'm gonna talk about
what that, what's behind that? What does it mean to
build an agent?
Um, in a few lines of code.
This code sample actually will run if
you have installed the strands and
the strands tools packages from Pi Pii.
If you have the default model provider
of Bedrock,
you can run this and run the agent loop.
So I'm gonna walk you through kind of how that works,
why it works, and then of course, um,
we're gonna talk a bit about the TypeScript release.
Nick's gonna come up and talk about how we've built it.
And so we'll follow through here, uh, strands,
the TypeScript release,
the model-driven approach to an agent loop,
and so on.
So first, I just wanna get this out of the way since
many of you are coming here to join us
now that we're releasing
as of yesterday into TypeScript.
Very excited about this. It's a preview release,
meaning 0.1 on GitHub
and NPM.
Same style of strands though. We've worked really
hard to bring everything we've had since
May when we released the Python SDK
into TypeScript.
That's the same simple interface, a few lines of
code, run an agent loop.
There are some limitations though in this preview release as
we get to a 1.0 that is on parity
with Python. So just note,
this is about building single agent systems
today. We haven't added in our multi-agent
patterns. Some other functionality might
be missing.
We're gonna fast follow here in a few weeks with
things like open telemetry,
um, but today you can use our basic features
like Bedrock and open AI models.
You can use the async and
non-Async with streaming.
You can do full agent state and
conversation management, so for multi-t agents, of
course,
and hooks to inspect and change
that life cycle if you've started to play with strands.
Hooks are a powerful feature for
both observing and, and changing behavior
at different points of the life cycle.
So, let me step back and talk about for both
of these languages, for Python and for TypeScript,
what does it mean to have a model-driven agent?
And I'm sure some of you are building agents right
now. This is old news to you, but
for those of you who haven't yet gotten into this, it's
worth pausing on because I think a lot of folks
think about agents as what if you just
had LLM calls and you've given
them internal external tools like with MCP.
That's not quite agentic. It's a very broad
term. I think the industry is still defining it.
Our definition here is that agents run tools
in a loop to solve a goal.
And the designing those behind strands that I'll talk
through as we go,
is all about enabling that loop.
So you can think about strands as governing that identic
loop up top,
where the input that you give that loop
is the prompt.
And that's both system prompt, and of course what your
users are prompting your application with.
And what you're getting back is the end result.
In the loop,
you have a powerful reasoning model
that's equipped with tools, and
the goal you've assigned it through the system prompt.
And it's going through its own reasoning to
figure out how to use those tools.
Whether the information it's gotten back is sufficient
for solving that goal.
It might run more tools if it needs to.
And it completes that cycle as many times as
necessary to return a satisfying response
to the user.
Throughout this life cycle,
we're gonna talk through how you can control it,
how you can add in, you know,
you know, ways to steer the model, ways to constrain
the model.
But that in a nutshell is it.
And you'll get really far, really fast
by just embracing this architecture where you
let the model come up with its own workflow.
And I'm gonna share more about that.
But first to kind of contextualize what's inside
that agent loop a bit more.
First of all, it's a model. That's
kind of the number one thing that you need.
And specifically a reasoning model that can
use tools.
These days, that's many, many choices. It
hasn't always been that case.
So think, you know, of course, the, the big
AI labs,
you can use Gemini, OpenAI, anthropic
models. You can use the latest reasoning
model from Nova.
Many of these models are available on Bedrock.
But Strands is designed to work with any
model provider. So you can go directly to OpenAI
or anthropics, first party API is an example.
Many more providers have that same interface.
You can also bring your own custom gateway.
So for instance, there's light LLM support integrated
in with strands in the Python library today. We'll
be adding that over time,
uh, into the TypeScript interface.
Many customers will bring their own gateway
as well. It doesn't have to be light LLM.
And there's a whole abstraction that we call the custom model
provider,
where in Python or TypeScript,
you can just define how to interact with that
gateway product
or another model provider that comes on the market.
And many open source contributions
to strands have been
uh model providers by users of
those models or the vendors themselves,
adding support to use strands with
those models.
And then finally, you could think of that top layer as like the reasoning
model choice,
but it doesn't have to just be reasoning model. So for
example, a very common pattern
is like, let's say you pick sonnet 45
as your reasoning model for the agent loop.
You can assign as a tool,
say, a stability image generating model,
that's one of the tools available in our community
package contributed by the stability team.
And that then reasoning model can use
other models that aren't reasoning models that
are designed for other purposes like generating images.
And you can mix and match within the same agent
that way.
You can call out to many models within the agent.
And then for equipping the agent
outside, we just embrace open standards.
I'll tell you a little bit more about our design principles in a moment.
But in a nutshell, you could bring any MCP
server, you can use A2A
for agent communication. All
the traces and trajectories can go off to
your favorite
open telemetry provider through Otel.
I, because tools are so important to the agent loop,
I just kind of wanna pause on like, what are the choices.
So obviously there's MCP.
You can use any MCP server
with strands as an MCP client, all the different
off types.
We continue to evolve our client implementation
as the MCP spec does as well.
And then in both Python and in TypeScript,
uh, you can bring your own function
and use that as a tool.
So if you've already got software or you just wanna pull in
some library that you wanna use and expose that
to a as a tool to your agent, you can do
that really simply.
We're providing in the Python package a
whole bunch of built-in tools.
TypeScript has just a few of them, and we'll be
expanding those over time as well.
But those are the similar deal. It's like
as if you've built your own tool as a function,
and now you can just install it via a package and import
it. And
I pause on that agent as tools pattern because I,
I think it's often,
uh, overlooked as a way to build
an agent. You may have heard of
this as the supervisor pattern in orchestration
contexts.
Think of this as like you're building strands, this, you
know, big powerful reasoning model, and
you may say, OK, I wanna build a,
an agent that's really good at interacting with
some back-end system.
So for example, I've had a customer who uses,
uh, the MCP server from
Atlassian for Jira.
And they wanted to specialize a whole agent on
understanding how to interact with their Jira system,
and they'll use features and strands like hooks
to parse out the tool calls,
um, because a Jira story might be so large that
it overwhelms the context window.
And that agent's whole job is to kind of understand what's
interesting about this story that I wanna return.
They've encapsulated that all as this sub
agent.
And they exposed that to that higher level orchestrator,
the supervisor agent, as a tool.
You get some modularity in that approach,
and then you don't have to always use a deterministic
tool, is my point.
An agent itself can be a tool.
OK.
So I'm gonna talk, I'm gonna start telling you a little bit of a story
of why we built strands and
the history behind that,
but to set the stage for that,
these are just the snapshot of contributing
guidelines, um, you can find in
our repos, specifically the tenets
that go along with how to contribute
to strands.
Uh, so I've summarized them here on the slide. They're
all available in the GitHub repo,
but, uh, if you're unfamiliar with Amazon's
processes, we're really big on tenants. These are ways of
defining how we make decisions.
They're meant to add tension with one another so
that when we as a team or as an open source
community contributing
to strands are making decisions, we
can use them as a guide to help us decide
about trade-offs.
I, and they also, I think, tell the story of
how we tried to build this software for you.
One is just simple,
and really importantly, simple for the same
abstractions from
your laptop prototyping.
All the way to running it in production.
So in other words, getting that simple agent
loop running should be very simple.
Integrating telemetry and logging later
should also be just as simple.
We've talked a little bit about extensions already.
So model providers, a good example of extensions,
tools, another good example of extensions, but this applies
to everything.
So hooks are a mechanism
to basically take over
control at a specific life cycle point,
before, after tool calls, before, after
model calls, that kind of stuff.
And then you can plug in your own hook. We
provide some as well.
For instance, there's a built-in hook to help you capture
retries from bedrock models for transient
failures.
I'm, so take on those kinds of extensibilities,
we apply that everywhere we can.
And then they're of course all meant to work together.
They're all meant to lead you down the right path.
As you start layering on more functionality,
the defaults built into our abstractions
are meant to give you a good time.
And you can customize a lot of this.
And accessible to humans and agents is kind of an emerging
one. a good tangible examples of this,
if you go to strands agents.com,
you can actually add lash latest/
LLMs.txt and
get this format of markdown
table of contents, basically
this LMs LLMs.text
or LMst.org, I think is the URL
for this standard.
And it's a way of exposing to coding
assistance or model training
documentation that is a HTML to
a markdown twin.
So as a human, you're reading an HTML document on our
website, we expose markdown for models,
and we make that available over a standard protocol that
models know or
systems around models know how to find.
We've talked about common standards already. That's just
as things emerge, we'll be adding those in. We
already support the major ones today.
So back to the storytelling then, I mentioned that that
Nick and I are from the Strands team.
I'm before that we were part of
the Q and and what is now known as Quiro
teams at Amazon and specifically
we were working on a project to help enable
other Amazon teams to extend Que.
You can imagine that it's not just one team
building these, you know, super agents at Amazon.
It's many teams collaborating together, sharing
their disparate expertise.
And this is,
what is it, Nick, over 1 year ago now, almost
2.
It's a long time ago we were doing this, so this is,
well, you know, at the very early days of Agentic.
And we were observing many teams,
uh, either building their own solutions around
the converse API or, or other APIs
right they're just doing LM calls, uh, in a loop
around some workflow they built,
or they were using off the shelf frameworks that were simpler
than that,
but still weren't really agentic. They certainly didn't
have the agentic loop that we're talking about today.
They really required you to spend a lot of time
in deterministic workflow.
That meant that any engineer who had a good
idea, any product team that wanted to build
something,
they were spending months getting something off
the ground, so from idea to
prototype and longer getting
it into production.
And so what we focused on is,
of course, because our demand was to onboard
dozens of teams to bring agentic
functionality into one sort of customer
experience,
we started working on another way.
And that's what led to these results, uh,
for example, from the Quiro team for these experiences
where they could go from concept
to production in weeks,
and that was our driving goal. We kept iterating on
this internal framework to achieve those goals,
adding the right functionality, figure out the right
developer experience, and resulted
in helping these teams and other teams across the Amazon
move really, really fast.
In May of this year, we brought it into
the public.
That was the initial preview release of Strands.
We've had, um, notable names,
um, giving us very generous, uh, mentions
on social media.
Um, we've been very lucky to have over
5 million downloads, as Swami mentioned
yesterday, um, 5 million downloads of the
Python SDK on PiPiyi.
Obviously we're just getting started with TypeScript and we're
hoping it, it helps all of you as well.
I, and I've been meeting with a lot of you. Part
of why I lost my voice.
I'm talking about strands and the agents
you're building, and so I, I'm so thrilled to
start seeing the signal from our initial
release in May through now that you all
are all building much faster because we,
we made strands available to you and seeing the
gains that that we were able to build
for customers inside the building.
So, let me come back then, um,
to the model-driven approach in this architecture.
So just to summarize,
the point here is that you as a developer
are thinking about very few things.
You're thinking about the goal you want the agent to do,
system prompt, and we'll talk about some techniques in a moment
for being more fine-grained there.
You're thinking about the tools to equip that agent with,
which can themselves be agents and
give you this modularity where you can break down
complexity that way.
And you're plugging this into an
application, prompting it, getting a result.
That's the agent loop.
I'm, and I wanted to differentiate that
from this sort of.
Very big spectrum in the market
today on choices either from UDIY
or from
uh frameworks that you can get from
any open source uh
provider.
It's the
shift between workflow driven and model-driven,
is how I coined it.
And the difference here is
who is defining the steps
that need to be taken to break down that goal
into a plan,
to make tool calls, analyze results
of those tool calls,
decide whether more are necessary.
And iterate on that loop until a
result is given back to the customer.
Who does that work,
right? So that what what we grew up with on the
Q team was all these development teams
were doing that work describing these workflows,
using the abstractions given to them by
these open source frameworks
or that they were building as their own homegrown systems.
They were doing all that work.
And what that leads to is a pretty
brittle system that also took you a
lot of time to build.
Developers had to anticipate new scenarios,
maybe a new category of customer question and a
chat experience.
More workflow is needed to be authored and maintained
to meet that use case.
And if it broke, you had to troubleshoot these different
steps.
The model-driven approach, and it's not just
strands approach, just to be fair, there's a lot of frameworks
that came out this year alongside strands that
help you with that approach.
So you push all that work into the LM
and then shift where you spend your energy steering
that LLM into different functions.
So let me go walk you through a practical example in case this isn't
clicking. So
think of like early chat GPT.
You come into a chat experience, and you
had a pretty powerful thing, right? If I was in
this scenario, I'm, I'm trying to debug why
I can't connect to a remote instance
in EC2, let's say.
I had a pretty good experience going into chat
GPD and asking a question about how to do
this, and I got sort of a natural language
set of questions or basically a tutorial.
Might have been better than reading through different docs, reading
through different blogs. I got a much
nicer response, but it wasn't personalized at all, right?
I think this is all old hat. You're all kind of getting
there. This was the pre-agenttic era.
I got asked the question. I got steps back.
Maybe those helped me, maybe they didn't.
So when agentic, and again, defining agentic
here is using tools with an agent,
letting it figure out its own work, I'm,
you could still go down this path where,
let's say in a Python framework, you're describing
the steps of the LLM calls and you're breaking your
agent down into specific calls,
you might then anticipate, OK, the
first step, let's check network connectivity.
And you're making a direct call to the tool
that handles,
you know, VPC APIs
or security groups or other things like that,
and you're, you're iterating down that workflow.
Until you get a response.
That works great. Like,
no harm done if you have an agent that works
like this.
The challenge is you had to do a lot of upfront work
to describe those steps.
You have to then parse the tool results and kind of figure
out, do I need to move on or not?
Maybe you kind of found yourself in a hybrid mode where
you're letting the model figure out whether to move on or not,
but you're still describing what the next step is.
If you decided, oh, I want this
experience that I'm building here to support
container,
uh, connectivity or maybe an off-premise
compute solution, not easy to,
you have to then not just add new tools,
you have to add new workflow steps and you have to incorporate
it into the flow you've built.
That's, that's the sort of gist of a workflow-driven
agent. Conceptually,
the model-driven agent is much simpler.
Just give it the goal, give it the tools.
That's it. I saw that from my,
uh, you know, initial example of the International Space Station.
We had the example of
weather in,
um, Las Vegas.
Those are examples of very simple agents,
mind you, but they work
and they work because all you're doing is setting this
up
using an orchestration framework like STRANs.
Now, It does
sound too simple to be true, and to some extent it is.
You can get a prototype going really fast,
but the number one question I'll get when I meet with
you in a customer meeting.
OK, but I wanna give it
better instructions. I want more predictability out
of the workflow. I maybe I want it to go faster,
maybe be more cost efficient,
uh, in terms of token usage.
I'm maybe
there are some dangerous outcomes that the model
might take. I really wanna make sure it can't
create those dangerous outcomes.
How do I steer it? How do I constrain
it? So my story
here.
Think about this as a spectrum.
And think about where you're shifting your
work, and how big are those chunks
of work.
So if you're thinking in a workflow driven agent,
you're doing a lot of work upfront to define the
workflow, then you're iterating on that workflow,
and your controls are intermingled to the
workflow. Your guidance and steering and
prompting, your tool use, your, your
parsing of tool results, that's all intermingled,
and it's all monolithic.
A model-driven approach says, forget all of that,
start with just giving the model free reign to
figure out its own workflow.
And then, as situations require
it, layer on other controls.
And you can do that at finer granularity
for specific situations.
So let me try to break that down.
The left side of the spectrum, pure autonomy.
You give the model its goal, you give it tools, it
does its job.
Your tools in this situation are really your system
prompt. I'm
try to make it really good.
My advice is always make it goal-oriented.
Models love achieving a goal.
Tell it what success looks like. It'll probably
do a pretty good job
of finding success for you.
Research assistants are a good example of this,
right? Models have all the sort of knowledge they need.
You can give them external sources, you can tell them
what you, what format you want. They'll do a
pretty good job.
And then you can layer in things in strands like
structured output.
There's a mechanism where you say,
hey, I wanna force,
maybe it's a markdown format you want,
maybe you want JSON to come out so you can
fold it into a front-end application.
I'm, that's something you can layer in at the left end of the
spectrum,
that doesn't require you to think about the workflow
and where that output is coming from.
You're just saying like, hey, at the end,
my abstraction framework strands is
forcing structured output, and it's working with the
model to regenerate until it matches my schema.
That's all taken care of for me. And now I have a
model-driven approach that returns output I want.
OK, but what if you need a little more guidance?
So when we talk about steering and SOPs.
I'm, maybe you've seen last
week, we launched a new repository on strands
called SOPs.
Uh, if you haven't, check that out. I'll have a link
at the end of the session.
This is really just a technique for
prompting, for system prompting in particular,
that we've developed inside Amazon. There's a
very large community outside the Strands team
that have been working on this technique,
and then we've decided to deliver it through Strands,
and it's very helpful in this use case. Nick's gonna walk
you through it in detail.
I'm, but that's an approach
of just saying, OK, make your prompt more structured,
give it a specific set of steps in
the prompt that you suggest the
agent take,
and you can use keywords like they must do this,
they should do that,
and the model does a great job both
following your guidance.
And adapting, right? And that's a big
part because it may sound like you're back in the workflow
driven approach again,
but what if a remote API failed,
your workflow would have to account for that if you're just making
LM calls, or the model
could figure out how to do a retry or another
data source it can call upon
while still achieving the steps you described in
your prompt.
Then on the far side.
You're thinking about how to apply
constraints to a model.
And that's where you're really trying to protect around sensitive
outcomes.
I'm hooks are an example of this
in strands itself.
So you can inspect after a tool call, make
sure the results, um, maybe passed
through a PII guard rail, um,
maybe you're parsing for certain information.
Um, that can all happen as part of strands hooks
where you get to basically eject from the agent
loop, do some work, hand back to the agent
loop. Another
example of this is, um,
external to strands, uh, the policy
engine feature that's shipped as part of,
uh, Agent Core's gateway product.
So this is like a hosted MCP server
situation where you can either, you can have an MCP endpoint
for remote targets. Those targets can be
APIs, they can be lambda functions.
You can now assert deterministic policies
to those gateways
and in other words,
protect the data sources before a
tool is called.
And also externalize that logic from
the agent,
where the agent can be treated as untrustworthy.
And the gateway is providing you deterministic
controls for let's say
can an agent call this particular,
you know, API for refunds,
um, before the customer was deemed eligible
and you have a token that that specifies they, they
are, right? Like don't let the model try to figure
out how to game the system.
You can actually block the model from making any tool
calls until it's providing the proof that you need it
to provide.
So think along that spectrum. That's the long story
short here. There's controls along the way.
We'll walk you through that in our website if you start
building agents on strandsagents.com.
Um, and I'm gonna transition to telling you just a
couple of those examples that we launched in the last
few weeks. So
I mentioned SOPs.
Nick's gonna go into depth on these, but just to reiterate,
it's natural language instructions.
They fit in, um, whether it's via
Python import in the, in this case, or
an MCP server, which you can use with TypeScript today,
um, and the format looks like this upper
half, this is kind of, this is not one file.
Upper half is an example of an SOP.
Bottom half is how an example in the Python
SDK of how you load the SOP.
Look specifically to these steps. Obviously they are truncated,
but you can give it these headings of step one
is a setup step, step two is this, and
then within that these keywords, these RFC,
I think it's 2519,
2119, RFC 2119.
These are just like standard keywords that of course models are
exposed to in training data.
The SOP mechanism is really kind of exploiting
that that knowledge that a model has,
and it follows these keywords quite well.
This has been something we've been experimenting with a long
time inside Amazon, and you really just
follow this. You give it the steps, you give it the
constraint keywords within those steps, the
model's gonna do a good job.
We're also trying to figure out, OK,
if that works,
you're, you're off to a good path, but
you're gonna end up with a large prompt.
So what we're starting to experiment with, and this shipped,
uh, this week as an experimental feature
in the Python SDK.
Is what I think of as modular prompting.
We call it steering is the name of the feature.
And it's a way of kind of breaking down
the critical bits of instructions, and then
injecting them in those life cycle hooks I keep
talking about.
And the mechanism is, is really
a, one of those extensible engines and strands
where you can say, use an LLM as judge
or a deterministic Python library, you could
bring in cedar if you wanted to,
and use those external to
the agent
to judge the trajectories that
the agent's taking. So it looks at their traces,
you can pass in basically the whole agent state.
Examine it
against, let's say your LM as judge
prompt is,
um, is the tone and voice of this
response from the model appropriate
for these brand guidelines?
And then you give it a response of like yes, no,
and the feedback.
And so the strands will basically pause
at the agent loop.
Interpret those instructions
and then if the agent is compliant with
those instructions, it just returns control of the agent
and if it's not um compliant,
it returns feedback to the agent
as part of return of of control
and the agent absorbs that feedback, tries again,
goes back through the hook.
So that's the that's the way to think of steering and
that's um I, I think it's gonna be a pretty
interesting place for us to go if it works out
it's gonna give you um.
Fewer instructions to give the model upfront,
so bigger context windows to work with, less
chances of the model
getting too much steering data upfront.
More token efficient over time.
And then we're also experimenting with plugging
this into episodic memory systems,
so that that feedback loop can happen
once for a particular agent's life cycle,
and it just gets better over time at following
those instructions without needing that external
hook.
Another launch that we, we made this
week is an evaluations library, and
this is a little tangentially related to my talk
track of like, uh, controlling your agents, but I
think it's useful because
you need to evaluate your agents at some point in
their life cycle once you get past the prototyping
stage. And we've had this gap in strands
for a while, not giving you the libraries you need
to quickly take your agent and build evaluators
against them.
We're also adding in features with a
strands-based agent that will help you
generate synthetic data set that's relevant to your
use case, and then build your evaluators
around that data set.
I'm, you can come in with custom evaluators.
There's some built-ins,
and this is designed to work with an
online evaluation system of your choice,
including agent core evaluation system, which was launched
this week, or others that you might be using.
I'm, and really just pair that
build time story on your laptop,
something that's really native to the SDK experience
with those online systems where you're doing large
scale evaluations.
OK, so,
we're finally done talking to me.
I
teeing up the strands type script.
I'm, we launched that this week, available
in preview, and it was a
bit non-traditional in a couple of ways that I'm
excited for Nick to talk to you about.
First, we build it with strands.
But it wasn't vibe coded, it was actually
quite nuanced,
and it was a collaborative experience as
well between the Strand's team and
agents.
I'm, and so
for that, I wanna bring Nick up and talk about
how we built it and how some of these features
helped. Thanks, Ryan.
Hi everybody.
Thanks for coming today.
My name is Nick.
I'm a senior software engineer at AWS
and I was the technical lead for
building and developing the TypeScript SDK.
Like Ryan said,
as a part of this presentation, I want to talk
about how we actually went about building out this
uh new feature, this new language for
strands.
When we decided to
support a new language in strands,
we wanted to be intentional about how we went
about building out the language.
We wanted to reflect on our experience building
out the Python SDK
and specific, and not
necessarily just focus on the easy DevE
that Ryan has explained,
writing an agent and a few lines of code,
but we really wanted to focus on the
developer's experience writing that code.
We spent a lot of time developing and writing
code for Python, so we wanted to
reflect on that experience
and see how we could improve it.
Python was originally written by a group of
dedicated engineers in Amazon,
who built the Python SDK
as a prototype originally.
They used a lot of these early Gen AI
tools to bootstrap their
development,
to help them write code faster to get
this uh up off the ground and
have a working agent loop.
We spent a lot of time with these early
AI generated coding tools to
write all of the code for us, but the problem
was they,
a lot of it was vibe coding. It wasn't very
high quality code that came out of using
these tools.
I spent a lot of time, we spent a lot
of time as engineers reviewing,
understanding, guiding, steering these agents
to get them to write code that we were comfortable
shipping and bringing out to production for
everybody else to use.
And I recently went back and uh
analyzed the initial release of strands for
Python, and it was about 15,000 lines of
code. So,
coming into TypeScript,
we were
going to be building a, a code base of a similar size.
So we wanted to be intentional about how we actually
helped our developers write all of this code.
Specifically,
we wanted to figure out how we can use agents
to write code better and faster.
And I break it into these two pieces
because we came up with interesting solutions on how to
do each of those.
So,
for writing code better.
We looked at agent SOPs.
So, Ryan introduced this earlier,
and to give a high-level overview,
it's a specification for writing agent instructions.
It's literally a standard operating procedure
that an agent follows in order to accomplish
some tasks.
And the great thing that we found using agent
SOPs
is that it's great at steering agents
for somewhat repeatable behavior.
SOPs were uh initially thought up
by one of our principal engineers, James
Hood, who was similarly
frustrated with these early AI generated
coding tools.
He would spend a lot of time trying to get good
code written out of them and spend a lot of
time debugging and
trying to get good results.
And out of that frustration, he came up with this
idea of agent SOPs,
and he shared it with the internal Amazon
builder community.
And it was
super, super successful.
The last time that I checked, we had over 5000
of these authored internally, used all over
the place.
Internal Amazonians love this idea.
And like Ryan said, we wanted to release it
as a part of strands because we wanted to share it.
It, it has been so successful to help
engineers guide and steer agents.
So, here's an example of the SOP again,
you saw earlier with Ryan, but I want to
get, go a little bit more in depth in how
it works.
So, you have the overview, you have the parameters,
and you have the list of steps that the agent
is going to follow in order to
complete its task.
Like I said, it's
really easy to understand why
this
gives an agent repeatable behavior. It's
really obvious what the agent is doing when it's following
these steps to accomplish some goal.
And as a developer who's trying
to write these agents to accomplish some tasks,
this means that this SOP is debuggable to
me. If an agent is going
through these steps, and at step 3, it goes off
and does something unexpected,
as a developer, I know that I need to go in at step
3 and give it more instruction.
We've worked on a couple of teams at Amazon where we were
writing the system prompts for these agents and
developers were worried or afraid that
if they messed with the,
the authoring or the, the writing or the wording of
the system prompt, it would
make the agent do unexpected things.
But using SOPs, it makes it obvious
and clear, it makes it much
easier for the developer to go in and
update this and have confidence that their
changes won't break the system.
Uh, I'm gonna be showing, uh, a video
a little bit later where we've actually done this in
our development of our agents for TypeScript.
So, like I said, this was, uh,
this idea of agent SOPs was very
successful in the internal Amazon builder community.
And some of the ones that we released are prompt-driven
development and codesist.
These were two of the most popular SOPs
because they figured out ways to guide agents
in really impressive ways.
Prompt-driven development
is an SOP that has an agent
guide you through a question and answer process
to refine an idea into an implementable
state. The agent will
ask you questions to disambiguate a
problem.
If it doesn't understand a certain aspect
of what you're asking it, it'll do research using its
tools or if it's in a codebase, it'll explore the codebase,
and it'll take the progress as it goes along, so you
know what it's thought and done along the way.
The really good thing about this is what we
found in the early Gen AI coding tools is
the agent likes to take the shortest path possible
to solving a problem.
And the shortest path poss the shortest
path possible
isn't necessarily the one that I want
it to take.
Sometimes I want to guide it to write code in a way
that my team is familiar with or use some functions that
I've written that it may not be aware of.
So, having this back and forth question
and answer process with an agent helps me disambiguate
the problem. It makes it very clear to the
agent of what it needs to do aligns
with what I want it to do.
Like I said, the output of this SOP is an implementable
task. It's a markdown file for how to
implement a feature in a codebase.
And we developed another agent SOP which
is Code Assist,
which takes this task and actually implements it.
So, it follows the test-driven development
methodology for writing code where you write the unit
tests first,
and then after that, you write the application code.
And we found that
guiding agents to write code like this,
again, writes much better code.
After it's written the features, I can go in,
uh, take a look at all of the code that it's written, and
then give it feedback on how to update and fix it to
better align with what I want.
After a couple of iterations, when I say it's done, the
agent can go ahead and commit this code.
So, using these two agent SOPs
together, we've essentially solved that problem
of how we can get agents to write code better.
The second part of the problem, which is how we can get agents to
write code faster.
We solved in another interesting way.
So, developers on my team typically
develop and write software uh
in a way like this, where,
uh, on one side, you have the team of developers
who are communicating with the individual developer
through GitHub,
and the individual developer might be
creating pull requests or issues
to track the progress of the code that they're writing.
They're gonna create and update pull requests
and they're gonna coordinate the feedback that they
get from their team to their local IDE
maybe they're running Kiro, CLI claud code, etc.
and they're doing that communication. They're a middleman in this
process for informing the agent
on, uh, what feedback needs to be done
in order to incorporate and get this change
approved by the team.
But we're spending a lot of time doing
that, staging the local repository
or staging your local code base,
um.
Understanding,
reflecting and responding to the feedback,
writing all of the test cases
for the code as well. So, instead,
we wanted to shift this
and
have GitHub become a member of the team.
So we've essentially,
we've taken advantage of GitHub's uh action
feature, a GitHub workflow,
which
is triggered off of certain events on pull
requests and issues
to trigger a strands agent.
Like Ryan said, we have strands writing strands code.
We have our GitHub workflows
triggering a Python strands agent to contribute
code to our TypeScript repository.
The Python code is now writing code for us for TypeScript.
And
using the system,
we're essentially adding a new member to our team
through GitHub.
The agent is acting as another contributor on our
team, and I no longer have to be the middleman,
understanding my team's feedback and passing it to the agent.
Instead, the agent is doing that itself.
It's reading through the GitHub issues, GitHub pull requests
to do that coordination, so I don't need to.
And this is how we solved the writing
code faster. I'm not being the middleman anymore.
The agent is doing that for me.
So, using this new paradigm of an agent
in GitHub,
we had to rework the SOPs that I mentioned earlier,
prompt-driven development and codesist.
What we came up with are these two agents, which I'm
calling the refiner and the implementer.
And there are slight variations
of the prompt-driven development and codesist
SOPs tuned towards GitHub.
So, the way that the refiner works
is given an issue with a general feature
that I want to implement in the codebase,
it will read that issue, it'll have the
repository checked out and it can explore that repository
to understand the implications of implementing
that feature in the code base.
It'll then come up with a list of questions and
then post that as a comment on the issue for me
to go in,
uh, review,
update, and give it instruction on what to do next.
We repeat that process of question and answer through comments
on the issue
until the agent determines that it's ready to implement,
and then we can give that issue over to the implementer
agent. The implementer
agent, just like Codesist takes that
implementable task, which is an issue,
creates a,
a branch in GitHub.
It has the code base checked out, and then it goes
about implementing that code, that feature using
test-driven development,
and it makes a commit to the branch and creates a pull
request. On that pull request,
again, just like any other member of the team, I can
leave the feedback on the pull request, and it'll go ahead
and read that, and then update the code for me.
And again, now I'm just iterating.
The really great efficiency here is that
I don't have to sit down, write and debug code for
a half hour. I can let the agent do that and I can
go do something else that an agent
can't do.
And again, that's where we're really getting the efficiency
of writing code faster with agents.
So, I want to walk through a couple of examples
of how we've actually used this to write code in our
TypeScript repo.
Here, you can see the, uh, the
issue of an overview of a,
a task that I want, I want to implement in the
TypeScript codebase.
And as a developer, I know how I
might want to go about doing this.
But if I were to give this to an agent, it would take the shortest
path possible to implementing this feature, and that's
essentially what we're calling vibe coding.
To avoid this, I type in a slash strands
command to kick off a GitHub action to trigger
the refiner agent.
You'll see in a second, a label will be added
to the issue to indicate that this agent is running.
And the agent will be dropped in a codebase
with this issue as instructions to go
about and explore and understand how that issue
should be implemented.
It leaves a comment here
with clarifying questions on how it should go
about implementing that feature.
Now, while it's done that, I've gone off and done something
else, and I can come back
and answer its clarifying
questions. So here I go, 12345,
answering all of the questions.
And when I'm done, I can go ahead and type
in slash strands again to
trigger the refiner agent, and we keep doing
this until the task is ready to be implemented.
This takes a couple of minutes, um.
And once it's done, it'll trigger the agent again.
And the agent again is dropped in the code base.
It's able to read my updated comment,
and it ultimately decides that the feature
is ready to be implemented.
And it leaves a comment for that,
which you'll see in just a second.
There we go.
So, the agent has responded with a comment
on the pull request, and then it's also updated
the issue description
for the implementable task. And you'll see I'll refresh
the page,
and
the agent has actually made the edit
to the description here.
So, using this refiner agent, I've essentially
disambiguated the task for an agent to go ahead and
start the implementation here.
Now, in this next video.
I'm going to go ahead and trigger the implementation
agent. And it's really simple. I
type in slash strands implement,
and we're using the GitHub action again to trigger a new
agent, which is the implementer, to kick off the
implementation process.
Uh, again, we add the label, we create
a branch, we drop the agent in there, and it's gonna follow
this test-driven development methodology
to go ahead and start writing the code in our codebase.
I think this one takes about 30 minutes. And again, this
is where the efficiency comes in. I can go off and do something
else while the agent is doing that.
I don't need to sit there code and debug. I'm
just doing the review and uh bar raising for the code
that comes into our codebase.
So, here it's created the issue, but
something interesting I want to point out, which is about that steering
and refining the agent SOP is
the agent wasn't actually able to create a pull request.
We found that when
designing these agents, in some cases, the
agent didn't have permission to do it and needed the developer
GitHub token to do it.
So we added an extra instruction
to the, uh, the SOP to
tell it to give me a link so I can do it on your
behalf. And that's how we've
essentially debugged these SOPs.
So here, I've gone ahead and clicked into the
issue or the pull request, I've created it.
And you can see this is the code that the
agent has created on my behalf. I haven't
done any of this.
So, I'm gonna skip ahead here a little bit.
Now, I've instructed the agent to
update the description. Again, I'm not doing any of this. I'm telling
the agent to do it.
You'll see the comment just below.
And I've also spent a little bit of time
leaving a a couple of pieces of feedback on the poll,
on the poll request
for how I want the agent to update the code.
There were a couple of things I didn't quite like. I wanted to change
the naming of a discriminated union.
And I'm going to go ahead again and trigger the agent.
And after a couple more minutes, it's going to
go off, write the code, update the pull request.
And leave a comment.
We've refined this SOP a bit as well to
not just leave comments, it's also gonna respond to the report
request comments that I've given
and give insightful responses on how
to do it. If it's confused about how to go ahead
and implement a feature, it'll ask me that for
clarification before it actually goes and does that.
That's again that um refinement of
ideas.
And you can see here, it's responded to the comments that
I've given it saying that done, I've implemented this feature, done,
I've done that one.
And I'm gonna scroll up and take a look at the code
as well
to show that it's actually implemented this
feature. So
Using the system,
the team has been really excited and really
motivated to write code, and we found a lot
of efficiencies out of this. It's not just
me using it, it's our whole team,
and a lot of us are getting really good results.
I showed the system to my team's principal engineer,
Aaron, and he gave me feedback
of this.
I spent 1 hour of my time over 3 short
20 minute sessions total,
instead of perhaps half a day writing code.
Put it another way, I
saved my principal engineer about
4 hours of time and instead he was able to implement the
feature in about 1 hour. And I've
essentially 4xed the efficiency of my principal engineer.
It's not always quite this
efficient or quite so time saving,
but we are finding more and more efficiencies
on how to use the system.
Like I said, the real benefit here is the asynchronous
nature. I can go ahead and kick off an agent
or multiple agents to implement multiple features
while I go off and do something else in the meantime.
Things that agents aren't quite, uh, yet
able to do.
And we typically find that low to medium
complexity tasks are the best ones for agents to pick
up. As a developer, I'm going to focus
on the high complexity things and break them down into
medium and lower, so I can again delegate that to agents.
A graph that I really love is this next one.
We've actually kept track of the contributions that the agent
has made to our code base.
And you can see that our agent is the, the largest contributor
of code.
It, so, uh, my username is on
the top right. I have 43 commits in about, what
is that, 14,000 lines.
The agent has, is just a bit
ahead of me,
and is the, the biggest contributor.
And all of our engineers are using the system
to contribute code.
But I also want to highlight that as engineers,
we're still writing code, the, the agents aren't writing
everything for us because there's still
complex tasks that the agent aren't necessarily able to do,
but we're finding efficiencies and really good ways
to utilize these agents
and help,
help us speed up the development of TypeScript.
So, some closing notes that I wanted
to give here was that.
We've learned to spend less time writing code as
engineers and offloading that to agents.
If I were to pick up a feature for a code base, I have to
check out the repository,
do some context switching to understand what the feature
is that I need to implement, go through the
code place, the code base, write the code,
debug it. Once I'm done debugging it, I have
to write the tests for it, etc.
And instead of spending all of that time doing that,
I can offload that to the agent.
My time is much more valuable spent
reviewing, refining and bar raising that code,
and giving high-level guidance on the direction
and design that these agents should implement the code
in. We're figuring out how
to paralyze parallellyze our time
offloading that coding and debugging
process to agents, and I can go do things that agents aren't
able to do.
And
using the system,
we've essentially learned how to treat these agents
as members of our team.
If you remember back to that diagram that I showed of
the, the GitHub flow of us con contributing
to GitHub, the agent is just another member
of the team.
It's the, it's for TypeScript, it's the highest contributor
of code in our team right now.
And
I think that's really exciting.
We're gonna keep on working and developing the system and you can
track our progress on our TypeScript SDK repo.
Um, but
this is how we built TypeScripts. I'm really excited
to explain how we built it, and I'm really excited for all of
you to give it a shot
and try it out.
And I'm gonna hand it back to Ryan for some closing
notes. Thanks,
Nick. Uh,
yeah, well, I hope you learned a lot from us today
about what Strands is, how it can help you.
Obviously our team's been using it to get
efficiencies on code-based agents.
We've been working with customers who are building chat
experiences, data processing pipelines,
research assistance.
Strands is very flexible for all these use
cases
in TypeScript. Now you can get even closer
to applications running in your browser,
running in your client. Applications.
One of the things we didn't mention today, this week
we worked with the fine folks at Co-Pilot Kit.
They implemented an AGI integration for
strands
that's available on our website as well.
Um, so the QR code takes you to strands agents.com.
You can also find all the repos that we talked about
today. So SOPs, evals, of course,
the SDKs for Python and TypeScript
at GitHub.com strands agents.
I'm
Nick and I will be around for it looks like another
10 minutes if you'd like to ask any
questions, um, we also have a
few strand stickers.
Uh, if any of you are going back to the Venetian
Expo hall today, there is a Strands booth.
You'll find it in the big, uh, AWS
square in the middle of the expo hall.
Um, we've got in a, uh,
hot red orange excavator
running around that has an agent running on
it, so strands running on local
compute
managing sensors and then connected to
a cloud-based environment
to do, uh, an industrial manufacturing
use case and, and, uh, excavation.
Uh, so have a look at the booth if you're around.
You can get some more stickers and swag there
and have a chat with our fine folks about anything
you need. Uh, otherwise, yeah, come and, come
join Nick and I, and thank you for spending time with us today.
Thank you so much. Great
job.